[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everybody how's it going what
are you biting on why are you biting on
the cord
we're playing far cry 5 hours of
darkness DLC set in Vietnam is it during
the Vietnam War
yep okay cool I'm like my Hardy here
with Jake Decker what's up you played
this last week of a fair amount of it
right yeah I played a little bit we will
start a new game those two you guys can
get the setup and this is one of three
DLCs they plan the next couple being I
don't know the I might getting beginning
the order wrong but they're zombies and
Mars mm-hmm but there was one more that
there was no you're right they're three
so this is similar to like Blood Dragon
it's not a standalone thing do you need
to own the game to play it yes yeah but
it is its own like world standalone kind
of yeah you're always purchasing stuff
don't carry over all your weapons with
this voice acting is really on the head
yeah I was impressed that they didn't
play CCR at the beginning fire staple of
any Vietnam and I mean they played a CCR
sounding song
but really Yoko you missing the war was
already over j7 for me to Moses when
accidentally shoot Yoko yeah you'll need
the right intervention on that one look
sharp man here we go my job was to ride
shotgun
that's why they called me cowboy
well that didn't work out but is the
intro as you may have expected the
chopper went down much like it did at
the beginning of the main game speedy
ass what game is this this is far cry 5
hours of darkness it's available as of
what tonight midnight war I think so
yeah and with your brothers
June fentons official so love Ubisoft
Shanghai okay so does this relate at all
to far cry 5s main story like this is a
flashback of one of the character to
something so far no you're not Nick rye
or anyone right no I don't think so I
think there are characters in this
though from the main one I haven't met
any of them but
besides give me a favorite cowboy you
were what so the narrator just died oh
really yeah he was the narrator I think
it sounded like it I thought he was
talking to cowboy yet being you yeah
yeah see that's the voice right there
doesn't sound like it does it maybe I'm
wrong yeah he said do me a favor cowboy
like
this is xbox one not 360 but we're
playing on PC huh someone asked is Xbox
one or 360 we're playing on PC but it's
coming to Xbox one sorry I don't think
so
maybe like some indie games and like
sports games oh is that right Joe Danger
eighty eight said you play the guy you
collected all the lighters for in the
main game uh I mean I don't every kind
of cool I'm not entirely sure so like
the Mars DLC is presumably one of the
character in the future I forgot
I mean look up his name cuz yeah you get
like what twelve thirteen lighters yeah
all Vietnam lighter locations
what they carried side-quests give the
mouse arrests holy hell nah
so his name is Wendell Wendell read ler
Wendell read ler take a cowboy I guess
so yeah he's wearing a cowboy hat that's
cool I mean it gives them an excuse to
do weird stuff like this
I mean it's essentially the far cry 5
formula put it in the Vietnam setting
right yeah nikka riah's Mars
I don't know I'm assuming chase the
gamer on YouTube is joking maybe serious
I have no idea man this is just cut and
paste main game running from them though
yeah
yeah it should look somewhat familiar
kind of remind me of the beginning of 3
when you start out in the cage and then
you start running away from her Mathews
yeah it's just an excuse to get you
stranded in the foreign environment yeah
bamboo stick is a melee weapon yeah I
feel like it wouldn't be a very
effective one but yeah Nepgear on
YouTube we were just talking about a Joe
danger anita was just saying we're
playing as Wendell red ler or Wendell
red ler in Holland Valley from the main
game he's the dude you get all those
lighters for the Vietnam lighters that
the Things They Carried sidequest what
they carried quested in Far Cry 5
and ya Hussain Allah booty I'm apologize
if I butchered name yeah it's a
character you do this kind of major
collection and miscellaneous side quest
for so it's a flashback obviously from
Far Cry five story you get like the
old-school m16 and this presumably I
didn't get it when I played but I didn't
play that much so looks nice yeah nice
like color palette change I mean this is
cool I actually obviously freeze next
week but I love Blood Dragon like as a
standalone thing that was much more
standalone than this you didn't even
need Far Cry 3 to play it there's just
an Xbox Live Arcade release and I liked
it it was a I mean the Far Cry formula
is well used in other games in series
too but I haven't even I played I
finally beat Far Cry 5 main story but
I'm right here and I think the objective
DLC is to extract so get to the
extraction point which is kind of cool
so like basically you just wanna get
from point A to point B however as you
can see there's all these things to do
like rescue Joker rescue Moses rescue
yokel and destroy a guns and as you do
that it'll make life easier almost like
I mean a lot of not a lot but they're
more games are doing that now like you
can go and get it if you want to and are
good enough but like breath in the wild
like if you prepare then yeah that's
kind of what it seems like in the buddy
system returns to so the three
characters you rescue can be your buddy
oh cool well that's even how God of War
was you could kind of speed through the
main quest if you want to it would be
harder though yeah or as is it a lot of
people did you could take your time and
explore my world I play Far Cry 5 on ps4
though so I'd have to give
it's a hussain allah booty it's a bamboo
stick and yeah this is out tonight June
today's June 4th obviously but tomorrow
June 5th or like tonight I mean I guess
technically what New Zealand Australia
and eight or so hours I guess it is
available on all three platforms these
PC ps4 Xbox one and you do need to own
far cry 5 in order to play it how do you
access it is it through so it's the main
menu the only reason I didn't show that
was cuz spoilers just in case you
haven't finished far cry 5 but yeah
there's like an option menu that's I
think it's called add-ons okay I'll talk
over here oh this is kind of cool this
is one thing that I had done beforehand
well your binoculars and scheming as it
v-b-e pull up a knocking Z there you go
see
it's actually like gets me excited to
see how they do zombies and Mars yeah
I'm
I think I'm most excited for Mars I
think that could be pretty interesting
so one cool thing about this DLC is that
you can call in airstrikes follow me in
there call in one there you can call to
it oh I see you can call multiple you
have to unlock it's like as I was saying
as and pretty easy undetected that's
cool that you're so the thing is is that
I use my - I have to like complete other
objectives in order to get more air
strike oh they're not on yeah that's
cool was it napalm doesn't pop yeah I
keep expecting CCR to come on yeah right
oh you get air strike tokens yeah
clearing camps
I think completing objectives and you
get them but like I think different
areas of the map if there's an a a gun
near there they can't help you so you
have to like take out the a guns not a
backseat but you just passed over an 8k
back there oh that's what I was looking
for oh there we go I love the reload
animation with the a K and far cry so
they like push one magazine oh yeah
timesplitters did that - very
how many there there are a ton of
Vietnam games there was a black ops one
had it someone was just talking about
there was shell-shocked was it called I
believe shell-shocked or that which I
didn't play much I don't think it was
very good I think I think the sequel was
there they came out of the sequel and it
was decent but I did I still don't think
it was that good
there's that uh there's that a steam
game
I think it's steam game that's a Vietnam
conflict Vietnam yeah I forget what it's
called I know Aaron Sampson in the
office was pretty into it when it came
out
oh I mean speaking of battlefield that's
cool the fact that it's tied into I mean
it it's not a crazy amount of effort to
tie into Far Cry 5 obviously there's
gonna be zombies in Mars but that makes
me want to play it actually ooh
throwing knife right orchestra to
Vietnam oh yeah that the one you were
talking about I think so yeah that was a
cab stir on twitch that mentioned it
yeah people are saying this reminds
known Far Cry 3 aesthetically I guess
that makes sense just uh where were
those where Far Cry 3 is the rook
islands but I forget what like where
geographically you're supposed to be
might also have been Southeast Asia
probably
[Applause]
you a nice little Vista that's what I
was talking about so I need to take down
so being in a location with active a
guns will block airstrike usage destroy
a guns with explosives and I think yeah
there we go so you can go to the go to
the a a gun see it from here but
have people like asked you yet how big
the map is compared to fire craft I I
don't know but I I think it's I think
it's my guess is that it's about the
size of one region you know there's
those three regions and far I think it's
the size of one of those maybe a little
bit smaller look at the bigger cuz I
mean like Far Cry fives map didn't
strike me as massive but it was
definitely big yeah
and just watching you play again and
like thinking of how they'll do zombies
and Mars makes me
I loved Far Cry five so much it's one of
my favorite in this series the story I
think was forgettable but yeah I mean
just like overall I think it was a great
open-world Bob Jones is asking you if it
it seems like you would agree it still
feels very much like a far cry yeah it's
it's very far cry I do like the set up
and I like how you like I like the idea
of just like your objective is just to
get to extraction it's not like you need
to I mean you do end up destroying all
this stuff but I think it's really neat
that it's just like yeah you're trapped
in Vietnam get out of here get some save
some dudes on the way that crash would
yeah POWs they're going whole like
really hard into the Vietnam tropes it
seems yeah
which it's farcry so the last time they
don't stand alone ish thing like this
was a pretty true trophy with 80s yeah
since stuff that's a good game yeah I'm
kind of I'm almost surprised they didn't
do this standalone
yeah they were the benefits of I guess I
mean requiring people to buy five to
have it makes sense money-wise it
definitely I'm not one to get season
passes but if you really liked Far Cry 5
like the season pass seems like a pretty
dang good deal you're getting three more
mini Far Cry games for what is it like
30 bucks more I'll look it up
yeah I mean the appeal of each new Far
Cry game to me is the setting like when
v was announced it's gonna be Montana I
was like oh that's interesting to see
how they'll do that I mean you can kind
of imagine what a Far Cry game is gonna
be it's that typical Ubisoft open-world
I shouldn't say typical again I think
Far Cry 5 did it like AC origins and
went a few steps in the right direction
for their open-world formula which had
gotten kind of stagnant
I like how they made it a little more
organic and how you come across quest
rather than go take the tower go take
these outposts you're still doing the
outpost but they make a joke of it in
Fargo fi that you don't have you towers
anymore
yeah no towers in this either thankfully
which makes sense I guess because even
more cuz you're this injured guy it
might not be just into super climbing a
lot I don't know season pass for far cry
5
lighters can be oh yeah lighters look at
that alright as so your Wendel Headley
what redly season pass so oh yeah
they're right so it is Nick Wray on al
Mars so I'm curious if the zombies will
actually be another open world thing or
because it says horde after horde of
zombies
oh you think might just be like a horde
mode yeah curious I mean my issue with a
horde mode zombies this is that that's
every map that everyone makes on the you
play or if there's so many hordes on the
map creator editor I know kind of
straight from the objective here so the
season pass is man they really make you
go through a lot to find a price on
Ubisoft oh my god thirty dollars
so this is $10 what we're playing now
plus the base game
actually MP 44 44 there was one on the
grandma's super than anything I guess
that makes sense it's like leftover
weapons goob we were just talking to the
dude you get collected lighters for in
fire cry five-window red lead you're
playing as him right now so this is the
flashback to what happened to him in
Vietnam prison camp should we do it yeah
is this one of the your dudes I think so
yokel or someone I'm gonna read about
the zombies quick see if it mentions
uh yeah I'm risking one of them I don't
know who it is
Joker Oh yep there it is New York City
b-movie director guy Marvel is destined
to be the next big thing he's in Fargo
oh yeah okay
just ask him join him in seven hilarious
scenarios to take on hordes and hordes
of the undead scenarios makes it sound
like it's not gonna be the fact that
it's seven different scenarios makes it
seem like it might not be an open-world
thing
window
stray alarm before they can know you got
it ah shoot
who's not a good plan of attack yeah
this is coop deal see yes you can do
this co-op - are there vehicles I don't
think so I didn't seen any that's a good
question
I'm seeing helicopters yeah I don't I
don't think they are yeah that is that
is weird actually come to think of it
this is the first time a Far Cry has
been based in a war was it wasn't there
a civil war going on in for I mean I
guess I'm sorry
yeah historical conflict cuz yeah you're
right for was the rebels and like what
uh Himalayan mountains yeah
- had a war - going on right yeah that
was more like a genocide I think I'd
love to see a spiritual successor to for
Earth sorry not for - yeah that's my
favorite part right
excuse me so the zombie DLC sounds a
little more structured seven different
scenarios
I am mr. Fox we would be playing co-op
but Jake is actually possibly expecting
work related pre e3 kind of call thing
so I might have to go solo so we didn't
want to set up co-op
so sorry did you talk about how the
perks work no there are perks I don't
know how to use them I got a said they
just upgrade as you use felt things and
that as opposed to a tree yeah so
there's definitely not a tree so see
these four things in the corner alright
there's something do it those I should
look at that I skip through the menu for
it would you play this weekend like an
hour
yeah bout an hour
aditya come on on youtube apologies but
what's your name this is like it's just
another mini open world where you're
surviving so as far as random mission
that goes you can come across them
rescue some other POWs and just
essentially try to escape but it's
another mini open world where we go they
didn't set off the alarm that whole time
no I shot it oh this is out tonight June
5th
firebase echo this is Python to five
I've neutralized the enemy can that
would suck if that thing's Joker thought
you were dead
oh he's got an m16 fighter base echo
Python to five with me now grab it well
that's it well that's in the main game
clear this is oh yeah it is huh and then
16b no drug ao8 we have not come across
any vehicles yet well not actually
actually sure all right and then Alex
Pendergrass and easily was saying that
there's permit off with these characters
oh that's kind of cool
well he almost died from a panther hurt
I wonder if it's more like the
Companions from the base game was just a
cool down I'm curious yeah I can kill
him find out
I can get him killed yeah yeah be fizzle
two two three four this is a new mini
open world map that you're just trying
to survive in during the Vietnam
conflict
just clothes though oh it does what was
that it was like a dud
come on it seems a little more sparse in
terms of like weapons available and
everything yeah rival II I guess look
it's one of those things that would make
more sense be a little more fun on the
harder difficulty yeah I could
definitely see that if there are
different you can't get video vehicles
sir
oh you can't apparently yeah everybody
saying hopefully it's a Huey I actually
I could see that when you escape maybe
you that icon is a vehicle isn't it it's
a a gun oh gosh okay look this way of
course I don't have any explosives I
don't know if I yeah how would that
makes sense if you're in a Huey wouldn't
you just escape why am I'm thinking you
get to the Huey
that's your extraction and then you like
there's like some explosive set-pieces
you fly out with it
easy I usually try to go stealth in' and
all the fire car games
[Music]
okay I got a remote exclusive backup
blow it up
firebase that go place on ya
apart from the shell-shocked alright so
I got five air strike tokens
okay so let's bomb you got plane
reconnaissance yeah
let's bomb a plantation bunker okay all
right
points-of-interest this looks prison
camp oh that's when I just clear that
but no I don't know if it's something
just cleared it's a pretty big map
actually yeah I think you're you're
pretty on point as far as being like the
size of Holland Valley or the whitetail
mountains or what's the name of the
river I have no idea but yeah I think so
maybe maybe a little bit smaller maybe a
little bit bigger
just like Vietnam I'm sure yeah I just
want to quote Tropic Thunder while I
play this get some nominated okay three
those automatically equal okay
give me another one I'm gonna need med
kits cuz I suck at video games you know
I don't want to rush to the extraction
just see what happens but I know if
people want to see it spoiled for them
not yet probably not
yeah Buick succeeded on twitch this will
be this release is technically June 5th
if you're on the west coast with us then
it'll be like 9 p.m. tonight east coast
12 a.m. and then other regions would be
June as well
I'm the dude plane that do disguise
oh hey buddy punch them lower back oh
he's right next to you oh I hit this
oh my buddy can save me yogurt as I'm
sliding down the hill oh no you can get
you come on Joker is that him I hope so
oh no no that was a dead dude yeah he's
coming oh boy did we get like early
access code from Ubisoft we did yeah so
I could be wrong I'm not like a gun
aficionado I believe the m16 from this
era like it would overheat really easily
oh yeah it was a piece of junk
yeah overheat it would jam a bit like if
it got wet it would have issues yeah as
opposed to the a K which is like still
most reliable weapon ever yeah
yeah you do need the game to download
this YouTube deal city on YouTube it's
it's technically not standalone Bob
Jones in the sense that you can't just
buy it by itself but it's like its own
thing once you get to the Far Cry 9 menu
I think that's where we're going I kind
of like these zip lines I kind of like
wasted time and a life by getting up
here coat whatever wait what
I like the all the zip lines here I
thought you said wasting I did waste
time because I could have just walked
over here and I would have already been
in my objective but that's a little fun
little detour I slid down the mountain
joker revived you yeah
be some IGI save yourself yeah punch
that music box yep yeah well look at it
it doesn't look like a radio well I
guess you can't look at it right now
but alright uh we should bomb this place
I'm thinking it's like it looks like
you're on the other side of it
that's okay looks cool
the reason we don't see a ton of Vietnam
games because of how complicated and
yeah our history with the issue is and
also the fact that like it's pretty
recent still yeah I mean like there's
World War two games left and right but
people are talking in the chat about the
ethics of this yeah it's kind of a weird
I mean I know like the Vietcong were our
enemies and on Twitter saying I think we
mentioned earlier in the stream the
games that came out earlier yeah I was
kind of hoping like or not hoping I was
like expecting this to be like a little
bit more self-aware but I can't be yeah
I figured it would be like the intro
kind of scene that but like yeah like
you said maybe if they did use CCR that
they're learnt leaning into our
perception of the war the Vietnam
conflict
yeah I don't know it was just such a
complicated conflict that ya know but it
is this is fun I am enjoying it yeah
Daniel Thomas on YouTube was saying
how's Vietnam pretty recent still the
war ended in 1975 it was actually never
whatever but I'm the Afghanistan like
Call of Duty 4 wasn't like I mean
obviously it was pretty much based on
what was happening but it wasn't
actually historical as far as uh they
weren't actual conflicts they were
talking about nukes and like obviously
the factions were based on what was
going on real life we actually did a
video on that back
I think this one is like a VIP target
that I need to take out it's like a
general tso bomb it too
Mike G bro on twitch so you're
essentially if you played far cry 5 bass
game you are
Wendell redly and he was the dude you're
collecting lighters for the base game
and then you crashed from he we got shot
down in Vietnam during the Vietnam War
and now you're essentially just rank
damn trying to escape so there's a
crashed pilot somewhere here I don't see
him though yeah how nearby knows it that
was a lighter yeah that cap no the cap
is 350 meters away oh well I'm not gonna
stay here and comb the area let's get
some action I wish you had like I know
it wouldn't make sense but I wish he had
the wingsuit for all these hills like I
looked down like oh man it'd be so much
fun to wingsuit down these valleys
that's why I was saying I was curious if
they were gonna go into like a fantasy
Vietnam conflict thing as far as like
putting the far craft formula into a
Vietnam historical conflict but it seems
like they're trying to stay more
grounded which is surprising considering
far cry fives tone aside from the
opening intro which is pretty yeah the
wingsuit right here would be great
you're gonna bomb it from all the way
over here
jeez I mean even with the tokens that
seems pretty Opie it's kind of like
artillery
oh no you didn't you you had to shoot
the mortars manually right in Fargo five
I think so
yeah I wish I could wingsuit down that'd
be so cool all right they're inside so
that's not gonna work
I saw someone asked if you get the m16a1
in the base scam it's a good question I
we can maybe we can look at the shop
after just to see if it's available I
don't believe you could before the DLC
came out yeah yeah yeah so I'm wondering
if like now you can yeah if they added
those to the main you know I want to say
so because I know they definitely added
that stuff to inside they added that
stuff to this to the map editor do I
have oh hell yeah
subtle Oh
Python 2 5 an nd8 commander was
neutralized yeah someone actually made
our gene Shepard just voiced when I was
thinking there don't seem to be as many
animals just randomly attacking you I
got attacked by a boar earlier now but
yeah it it does seem toned down huh
because I remember Far Cry 5 was kind of
ridiculous with it mm-hmm before was
actually worse and then five you only
have lobby ridiculous like birds would
be flying out of the sky and attacking
you yeah where you know mark him buddy I
hear yelling oh yeah I found this before
it's kind of cool there's like
underground tunnels throughout the map
too
Bunker's I guess you'd say that Emma are
the health pool aren't you
maybe I'm full pickles I know there I
know they can be trained to be vicious
but I love it why can't we want to shoot
like a corgi Oh a silenced pistol I want
to do that
I one thing I do like is that the you
can't just slap a silencer on everything
and this you have to find sounds weapons
just cuz like it gets so much easier I
feel like when you have enough to put a
sign on thrown like a sniper or
something like that you can just clear
them all out yeah right away
yeah goob I'm not actually saying there
should be a task or use I get I just
said that I get why they're using pit
bulls just I'm one of those people who
gets annoyed when people perpetuate that
vicious pit bull idea they can be
trained to be crazy badass crazy like
[ __ ] up but they're actually really
sweet animals this isn't the time for me
to do a stand about pipilok
what
I don't worry the gunplay being this
fast in Far Cry 5 no it was kind of
heavy like the weapons themselves yeah
actually felt like they turn that down
oh I was just here wasn't I yeah I was
totally just here great nice little
detour all right let's go yeah no no no
let's just hit this direction into the
fog what we go in for an hour total okay
about an hour 20-ish minutes little less
fewer let's check out what's over here
and then we can check the store although
if I go to the main menu it's gonna
spoil something I don't know if people
want to see that maybe we shouldn't do
that you go to the main menu yeah we can
finish the game the title screen changes
to something that's I'd say it's pretty
spoilery if you care about the story
though Oh from the main game spoiler
yeah yeah I would avoid that yeah can't
you access the shop here no you don't go
through the Ubisoft club wait sorry what
do you mean shop the end game lighting
women shop yeah to see if I'm 16 a1 is
oh right right okay you'd have to go to
one of your bases wouldn't you yeah and
I don't think there are bases in this I
mean we could always you could always uh
I can go back to our camera yeah I
wanted to if people really want to see
if that's there if not there's we don't
need to do it I imagine that would that
would just be too similar to the m4 you
can get I know it's not the m4 but that
face assault rifle that all the Eden's
Gate cult uses yeah
the honey badger
I'm really sorry from butcher named Duke
X Duke MA and the YouTube chat is saying
his family in Vietnam and like Saigon
pretty game yeah another lighter
Alex Pendergrass and YouTube said the
weapons are all unlocked in the main
game I'm downloading this DLC we could
show them I guess or confirmed if we
wanted to but yeah we'll just go to our
face cam while we transfer over you can
see what right there I've been already -
it looks like yep there's a bunch of to
your right on your compass up top that
showed like four people Oh yep it's
calling an airstrike again
actually maybe all so for Ubisoft the
conference correct me if I'm wrong is
Monday the 11th I think I know Monday
the 11th is a Tuesday I don't know the
12th is the Tuesday okay Monday the 11th
I believe is Ubisoft press conference
for e3 we know they've been teasing
Assassin's Creed Odyssey purported to be
vyek in Greece ancient Greece it shows
like a Spartan helmet though yeah it
should that spartan kick in that late in
any teaser um what else from use off
Division two they're gonna show I
believe that'll probably be hands-on
right I don't know I don't like we can't
talk about a lot of stuff yet but that
must be because they've that game has
been being made for a while from what
they've hinted at the crew to I don't
know if they're gonna show anything more
before that releases that releases in
June right like late June I think so
yeah week or two after e3 Ubisoft what
else am I missing hopefully like our
dream I know you and me are hoping for
some sort of Splinter Cell don't know if
it's gonna happen at this point I would
love for it to happen though yeah that's
what I want I'm gonna be bums with
Ubisoft at the Splinter Cell Beyond Good
and Evil - oh it's not by a paranoid
commit to high commander Jean Sheppard's
telling me it's not by ik my mistake so
somebody oh so it's you can choose
whether it's male or female so like
create a character I guess or just like
a thing a stand-in
that's a bummer I like to buy actually
for the first time in a while I liked an
assassin's Creed protagonist who's
alright I feel like I'm missing yet
beyond getting evil - I'm sure they'll
show more that whatever that game is
dang it reaction play we're ready
probably just dance hall oh yeah for
sure oh this is interesting what are you
most excited 43 or were you most hoping
for me yeah Splinter Cell for sure
what about like things are sorry what I
mean like CD Projekt RED had said that
they're bringing a game yeah I think we
all know what it is and I'm very excited
for that yeah but like that like we
don't know yet that that's what it is
but it's pretty obvious it is Splinter
Cell on the other hand like I don't know
I'm just if there's a Splinter Cell I'm
surprised it hasn't been leaked to you I
guess I have a week but like I'm
surprised it hasn't hasn't been more
like substantial leaks that's the thing
we every year we always like have a
pretty good sense of what's gonna be at
the show but there's always like maybe
four crazy surprises like I remember
Beyond Good and Evil 2 was that last
year was a crazy surprise yeah well
Castle was metroid prime for and michel
ancel was like no there's no beyond
didn't yeah
I don't cyberpunk 2077 is not gonna
release this year
they're gonna show it this year but I
highly doubt yeah I bet 2019 earliest
yeah
spring spring would be Witcher 3 was May
2015
we're just talking on the other day oh
yeah there's Superman the rumored
Rocksteady Superman game yeah I don't
care much about Superman but that would
be I love Rocksteady stuff as a lot of
people do and obviously they can do
Super Heroes justice if Batman's any
indication just this huh they can do
them some injustice oh I would have to
go with somewhere just mentioning
shadows die twice or blood-borne two
whatever that Cesar Rosa I'm really
excited for that goes to Tsushima from
sucker punch yeah go schema sounds cool
Rocksteady Superman if that happens that
I'm sure they'll be do you imagine a
Rocksteady game where you can just
[ __ ] fly everywhere instead of
gliding yeah I mean I feel like at the
end of like at least the the last Dark
Knight it was like you basically fly
everywhere
did you get the bat or whatever the
plane thing oh no I didn't know you
could I
no no I'm not asked that's what Oh
no no just like the gliding was like
super years all right cool that's
stranding I don't think we'll see
gameplay I think we will I hope so
a Justice League game and development I
wouldn't be surprised
damn yeah that was battlefield 5 I'm
curious to see hoping I'll get to play
it I know they'll have it at yet play
because I'm excited for that game
despite the trailer looking like an
action movie I like that they're being
honest I hope you'll play it but what
they said sounded cool but what they
showed I was like but yeah I'm excited
to play that excited for e3 man I feel
like it's been a whole year since we've
had meet there yeah yeah I hope it's
game plays well goo'bye uh I want to
know more I know like what was it was it
Shuhei Yoshida saying he played duck
stranding no but yeah a a Sony exact was
like trust me death stranding makes
sense after you've played it for five
hours and it's like no kojima games make
sense after you played them for ten
years yeah yeah I would like to see I
mean I assume it's an open-world act
they've said it's an action game right
open-world action game and uh knowing
Metal Gear Solid five which obviously he
was heavily involved in before he left
yeah I imagine will be more similar my
shadow the Tomb Raider Square has their
own press conference Kingdom Hearts 3
shadowed assume Raider hitman presumably
the rumored new hitman is that rumored
or confirmed that IO is doing another
one oh god I can't get through here I
think it's no no no I'm gonna die the
water's not that deep
stop swimming uh-huh
is this hurting me I can't tell it
sounds like it but it doesn't look like
it maybe it just like impedes your
vision and thinks I wonder what it's
supposed to be maybe it's like a story
mission thing
maybe I'll pass out in a little bit as
opposed to bliss from the main game yeah
all right I see some see some bad guys
Oh some Cody Gardner was saying it was
mark Cerny who said deaths training
makes sense every few hours oh it was
okay mark Cerny of a knack Fame knack 3
I could see that coming what's it called
uh Orion the whispering willows I might
be getting that wrong I that'll be dope
yeah the side of that did you see today
on the Microsoft Store briefly Dead
Island 2 had a December 31st release
date so weird number Techland handed
that off to forget the name of studio
but now Tech landed dying light and I'm
hoping to see a dying light to
announcement uh I
yeah I'm just hoping we see something
from tech land like I don't necessarily
need a dying light - yeah but I would be
really interested to see what they are
working on oh yeah Maci was I guess I
mistook Jake when he was saying about
the gliding I didn't think you can get
the batwing
there's the introduction of the back car
oh right yeah you had the Batmobile
driving around and that my favorite
Arkham game is still asylum yeah I think
I like the sound the most what that was
more of a Metroidvania than that open
world
no it's my a K don't have any K all
right it sounds pistol that's fine see
black ops for I'm actually weirdly
curious about black ops for cuz to see
how they do that a battle royale mode
[Music]
how many Battle Royale announcements do
you think will get that we don't already
know about whoa battlefield right they
haven't said they're doing battle royale
but they're like that would work pretty
well one for here I bet Microsoft
they'll have some like last unit
maybe it wasn't last year but they had
that one battle royale game that like
the whole thing is you can like there's
people who just watch and they can like
vote to like mess up the people playing
really weird I sincerely like I don't
think it's I'm not like I've tried to
love nintendo I love Stoney I love
Microsoft but I'm really rooting for
Microsoft this year to turn my
perception and around really - I mean
Gears five sorry halo 6 for sure will be
showing off whether there's gameplay
involved or not here's five I wouldn't
be surprised to see maybe that Dead
Island 2 news but that I want to like
I just did a video the other day about
why I'm never gonna get sick of zombie
games really why they're important but
that I own two would be fun to play but
that's not gonna really change
Microsoft's fortunes yeah especially
considering they just write out state of
decay - which I like but was a kind of
underwhelming misperception say it
politically okay I'm sure your pump for
smash to play that oh yeah that's
another excited have they said it's
gonna be playable or is that just pretty
much all signs are pointing to it being
one of their main thing I'm not sure
smash the Pokemon well I'd like to play
I highly doubt the Pokemon game will be
playable right good I could separate
entirely the switch game we still don't
know anything about aside from it's like
a mainline Pokemon RPG I gotta stop this
is this thing Jean Shepard saying new
crackdown 3 gameplay man how many I'm so
sick of crackdown 3 and I have even
plays yeah I love that first game too is
alright but then um I want them to bring
it out I mean if it's not ready
obviously keep it keep delaying if you
need to but that seems so cool what they
seem capable of with the cloud
destruction based City based cloud
destruction if I'm saying that correct
yeah something like that
well the stupid thing
the speakers yes she was small stop
talking all I bet it's down here yeah
the sound propagation is pretty weird
oh my god
just forget it all right it's really
annoying just put it on the freaking map
I can still hear it though don't you
fire a silenced gun to try to quiet it
there you go yeah I'm excited for e3 we
got the whole I'm sure if you saw who
was on GameSpot daily today John Luke
and Matt Padgett
oh I never saved private though so I
have to go back in here sorry
UK Australia crews are in town
Jake's about to go in and
[Music]
who's this Moses this is torture man
firebase echo hi i'm with private first
class Moses Walker now he's free you
wanna call it there yeah we can call
here let's find this radio gonna find
this radio
yeah she's it sound like a pole like it
sounds it gets up here right it sounds
like it's up here that's it oh it's
right like make it me no no here's what
I'm gonna do
no do it I did not want to go down the
ladder but nice I got it did she just
survive that and man look at Moses cool
as a cucumber walking down the hill our
beds on fire
I didn't realize until like today when I
heard this weekend I played a lot of
Fallout for just doing a video on that
just I didn't play much of it back in
2016 15 15 I'm excited to see what
fallout 76 is me too I'm important to be
online survival multiplayer it's my dayz
and rust are the two games they
mentioned but the rumors are also that
it'll still have like single-player yeah
and stuff later not a single player but
like a main questline side quest which I
think could be pretty cool yeah do you
want to cut to the camera bus so we can
go and switch to the main game and just
take a look at cool Jake for those just
joining Jake's just gonna check quick to
see whether or not the met weapons are
implemented in the main game so what are
you talk oh I see what you're talking
about okay
there's kind of spoilery
yeah I kind of don't like it they did
that but oh well um all right change
your tonight back do not know if the
next livestream is gonna be the vampire
am I saying that correctly that were
here ever hear what it is games so you
have to go to one of your faces yeah
you're right huh oh man I love the music
for this I do too people are liking your
air strike method Shh oh yeah I forgot I
can airdrop
this is a pretty cool perk I don't even
know if I got that when you uh when you
fast travel you can choose to just fall
from the sky that's cool I wish more
games did that not even as a perk but as
a mechanic yeah instead of just what
I've been doing all we can follow just
warping to a spot yeah that's just like
a little bit of contact like I don't
know all right yeah craft why is it
hitting me with all this finish the
freaking game and it's telling me how
this game works like definitely oh my
god okay
you
oh there you go right there Oh sick okay
that's it right yeah yeah and 16 the old
school one oh yeah it's got the Nova
rail system either anything else have
assault rifles oh it looks like there's
an older okay that one yeah older a
k-mer those both there no this is like I
already have this customized I don't
have this one customized oh sorry that a
cape specifically this one yeah yeah
just started here okay because I've got
I wanna see if I can customize this at
all
customers yeah that's what I'm hitting
right click yeah mm-hmm maybe I need to
equip it first
oh yeah there we go all right we'll look
at the other thing oh look the other
ones what else was there so I think
there should be new yeah the the dragon
Draganov pistol is already in 1911 right
so don't they would have added one those
just the skins yeah it doesn't look
added one of those shocked and I bet the
editorship melee weapons the bamboo
there oh yeah probably I want to throw
the bamboo at someone oh no it's not
here
oh this is new right m60 school I'm 60
that's pretty dope and cool I'll fire
this thing first
ec crimes on YouTube this is out June
5th so tonight if you're on the west
coast or midnight if you're on the east
coast of the United States or elsewhere
it's gonna be June 5th on all three
platforms yeah it's fun I like it yeah I
mean it seems like they scaled back the
insanity I guess which makes a little
more sense because you're server I mean
you're surviving in Fargo v but I'm yeah
only becomes to just destroy this place
but uh yeah so as far cry 5 hours of
darkness DLC it's out tonight for the
season passes $30 for ps4 PC and Xbox
one and then I don't the Morrow's and
zombie DLC I believe zombies might be
next
actually I'm not sure I don't know Nick
Ryan Mars and then zombies one those
will be down the road maybe in a couple
months or so yeah yeah well be the whole
GameSpot crew from all over the worlds
in the SF office here in California so
we will be doing a lot of III pre 3
stuff this week and then starting
Saturday with EAS press conference and I
know a few people will be down in LA all
ready to play some EA game for their
battlefield or I don't know what else
maybe they'll announce that Star Wars
thing they're doing I don't think we'll
play that but yeah should be a fun week
and now we'll have be covering
III as always Jake thanks for playing
hours of darkness thanks for joining me
see everyone bye
[Music]